you came on our show when Suicide Squad  was coming out and you were terrific I  thought as the Joker just a great  performance I was wondering if after you  played the Joker so convincingly did you  start to get a lot of offers to play  kind of deranged people because you  really showed that you you're terrific  actor but no I'm serious you really did  show this facility for playing someone  who's maniacally you know  psychologically damaged you know this is  the nicest thing I could say to you  thank you yeah  yeah I think there was a week that I got  an offer to play but you know for the  most notorious bad guys that you could  ever imagine I think it was like Charles  Manson and you know the guy from Waco  right you know basically the most evil  of the evil and I thought maybe I should  play them all and just make a box set  and be done watch me lose it all in one  box set and then not go back  you